ladies welcome right so what the [ __ ]
was that clothes off
Rippey clothes off holy [ __ ] what is it
the Spice Girls gone wrong Desperate
Housewives
I do not want desperate diners this
evening now 50 times yeah I want them
all to play there's the dog barks oh
[ __ ] they did bloody well yeah you can
better that but it's gonna take a lot of
concentration let's do the starter
together yes ready yes okay good
a really nice fresh fragrant broad bean
risotto with such a scallops finished
with lemon zest and some really nice
pshew yeah one cup yeah stock in the
rice has been cooked for two minutes so
we've just opened up the secret behind
risotto is keeping it al dente yeah yeah
bought bean puree mix it in a little bit
of Parmesan cheese touch mascarpone
cheese
what does it matter Heather three
minutes that's right gives it texture
and makes really nice and velvety Jackie
have you ever cooked a Scott no never
cooks Colin you never could have you
eating a prawn no holy [ __ ]
why not chewy don't like the smell how
did you know they're chewy never even my
darling just cuz I've seen other people
for shellfish across the world yeah it's
a [ __ ] expensive to look after them
thirty seconds for those scallops come
out enjoys my broad beam out and drain -
sure
nice and liquid yep thanks madam I'm
sorry you can't cook it and not taste it
now what's rubbering discussing about
that touch of olive oil to glaze it
gently on that olive oil yeah that's it
let's go Heather that side Jackie that
side yet so Jackie just described me the
flavor that skullet we just roasted
there describe it to me absolutely
gorgeous besides melts in my mouth
delicious yeah next week we'll go to a
prawn yes by September would have got
through every [ __ ] shellfish yeah
okay good
so on order four covers Table three for
risotto for pork chop for cherry samosas
yes yeah actually right Sarah four
portions yeah bigger pan there you go
come on Jay yeah they should be on
should be on the stove already Phillips
in a nice hot pan so the scholars don't
boil yeah sure
what do you think of that me ladies I
can't do it all my own that result is
lovely serious yes really really nice
work is the team good go very nice let's
go come on spaghetti is Jackie cake
Heather Sarah the Desperate Housewives
the desperate Heroes was so we started
the year and a half of death we realized
that we had something in common we like
to laugh we like to drink
we like food we cook different dishes
and take them around each other's houses
we just taste each other's foods and we
have fun an amazing food by little cook
you food I like to experiment with you
know if meats and fishes I've just
ventured into to eat so you come up a
cookery pot big enough so how many
recipes you could plan in your own head
yeah yeah I just love to cook apart and
I want to learn some new things yeah
bring it on he's a pussycat really
watery from that let me show you the
first one was perfect that looks like
water what we've done for these fellows
just taste that I like rubber bullets
now I got here yeah we start that again
please yes sir
Jackie yeah get rid of that [ __ ]
let's go on Jackie I really did explain
to those cops are this is what really
upsets but we've done that hardest part
by making the risotto when it comes easy
part
we're so letting ourselves down it's
like we've given up come on please now
back to beckylyn palace where my sheep
are living the high life
[Music]
my sheep have been staying in davie to
Victoria's vast garden for the last week
put them in the field of lush grass and
it becomes poor little bastards this
summits here and my sheep are getting
hot and bothered
luckily farmer may any shearing mate
Robin I here to show me how to give them
a trim even though the fleeces are only
worth about 50 pH we still have to share
the Sheep in the summer he should guide
them in command will be was hello MA
it's a bring them here like a [ __ ]
green cheese
hello MA that's [ __ ] work doesn't it
yeah shooing not only keeps them cool
but also stops parasites and flies
laying eggs in their thick wall so you
start from the belly yeah so quit my I'm
amazed how much came off it doesn't look
that big when it's on her does it she
looks a lot smaller no unbelievable a
feeling nervous yeah
watching him share the first you it was
time to have a go myself put this leg in
between your legs in between my legs
these boys [ __ ] 400 sheep a day the
pressures on
you keep the peace on the skin a bit / -
like that
[ __ ] you know but it's not going to us
the cioppino there's hardly talking
let's honor the secret is to share as
close as possible to the skin without
cutting the flesh this keeps the fleece
in one piece and back to killing me your
[ __ ] hole in mine this sucks maybe
with its Charlotte and Gavin are too
young to be shared their wolf hasn't
grown long enough yet it's amazing how
big the Lambs look now with just over
five weeks to go they need to be all the
30 kilos I can't see any problem with
that can you
no no Elijah there should be around the
35 kilos yeah when they will be ready
yeah conditionally yeah start
contemplating with jumpers it's been a
memorable day but little did I know it
was the last time I would see my lambs
Charlotte alive okay yes the last table
goes out just like the first devil yes
yes just as important right you have yes
Savas pretty nice table a good okay
result it can be stodgy sometimes but
there was something slightly acidic
which broke through it and it was really
good then with the scallops it was
really built er don't aside for me I'm
still kind of bringing out off my teeth
now so that was for me let the dish down
completely right results of the starter
wait how did we did I take blacks a
50/50 confident Jackie
1414 okay I'm afraid
only 30 out of 50 wife men resent in
undercooked under coach yeah yes 20
mm-hmm it refused oppose yeah you're
still in with a chance yes yes chef the
language alas is only got 33 next on the
menu it's a battle of celebrity plums
with beefy both at number two shocking
it [ __ ] is that I would even put in my
[ __ ] Bala name I join busy mums on
the school run
I always throws drop them off pilato's
back glass of wine I'm sure we've all
got nannies somewhere and as a death in
my flock could it be the Beast of
Beckenham Palace this is a possible
Wildcat on the loose
welcome back to the F word now it's time
for the main course pork chop very
nutritious low in calories very
versatile I'm going to roast it with
sage finish it with some brave and apple
a radicchio perfect combination this
thick line of fat round the back the
most important thing now is just cutting
through it and it stops the pork chop
from curling up
season
hot pan olive oil
it's really important to get the chop
and roll it down the back of the pan get
the outside layer of fat nice and crispy
garlic
but ER
bass
sage sage it's nice and crispy drain
masala that's gonna glaze the pork chop
leave that to rest because pork is a
very dense means we're gonna search
brave an apple with radicular shop
leaving the skin on but text Apple and
it doesn't disintegrate when a hit to
the pan
radicchio
[Applause]
Olive Oyl apples in season time and then
finally the radicchio salad in there
cider vinegar
and then just finish off the second sort
of olive oil and make this wonderful
warm so safe salad with a cider vinegar
inside
[Applause]
run it through
his chooses and I just sit a beautiful
chop
on that
with touch of olive oil
it's delicious who said poor boy
pan-roasted pork chop with additio
Braeburn apples done so cool chefs will
serve to proportion yes yeah into the
batter it's a really nice way of eating
courgette courgette some ugly slightly
bland nice and shallow fried like this
but it's a better dismay nice and light
crisp get rid of the water I'm making
pool jet yeah taste of something right
take mouthing oil nicely seasoned yeah
rock salt shred away so absorbs the salt
okay play out please
all right it's predict you Apple send
with a plate shop yeah beautiful on
there sit on just crisscross in step and
then your sage these now Jackie yes
please tell me yeah yeah no bit sauce
yeah one style pork chop touch a bowl of
all to cut the richness of the sauce yes
would you pay for that yes right are we
ready yes yes for pork chops away and
Sarah do not forget to smile my god when
we get the chops out make sure they're
all the same size why then the other
watch out watch out watch out over there
right yeah Jackie you know that walls
not hot enough
Yeah right go on I don't need to see
them to rest they look fantastic right
come here Jackie leave that [ __ ] coming
together yes chef yes JB it's a it's war
it's what it's wrong it's wrong
yeah actually the altar boy was putting
the poor no it is it's undercooked what
table is that it's about free okay come
here
look it's nice to have it just on the
medium but what is that come on sorry
chef okay ladies yeah we do that whole
table again yes everybody's just started
not off a little bit yes any hope in
hell I'm coming to Terry's and cooking
you've got to pick up the pace yes yes I
believe anyone can cook great food fast
and I mean anyone let's go
you start at certain to point in the
morning and you cannot stop George come
down places type cricket
you can't something go half past five
that's it grab my coat and I'll leave
Molly can you come down please
it never stops running this household it
is just the busiest job in the world I
think sometimes food is just the lowest
priority of the day if just to get fuel
in them and let's go at the moment I
feel that I'm picking the wrong food
because I'm really not cooking and I
love cooking from scratch but I don't
have the time to do it I believe
everyone has the time to cook so I've
come to spend the day with Sally to show
how she can cook delicious and healthy
fast food even with a busy schedule so
busy mama for very yeah I know how you
feel because we've got four kids wrong
what are you cooking at the moment for
kids the odd frozen pizza well that's
not actually cooking for mrs. chicken
nuggets what are you personally cooking
oh yeah no no I know I mean on the
weekends I will make the roast it of
course I will when I've got the time and
the energy but otherwise in the week
it's quick fast convenience convenience
fee what's what's next on your list this
time job can't help me actually
[Music]
I've got lights but once so the other
half of these maybe my bed's major yes
yes next
so another logo and this must be on this
program I'd say about three times a day
I cook for a living yeah when Tanis sees
what I've just done I'm in trouble and
just on what I've seen you know you are
one hell of a busy mum you know that yes
yeah and you know you've got everything
so well coordinated don't you think you
haven't got right yes is the food isn't
it yes yeah I'm gonna come up with a
dish that will be done in two parts I'm
gonna start it mmm
stop it go off pick up the kids come
back and finish it perfect 15 minutes
okay so we'll be cooking a far from
delicious leak and smoked haddock
risotto all things a risotto is about
standing over a pan for 45 minutes
but with this fast risotto you pop all
the rice and stop for four minutes to
speed up the cooking later the reason
why I kept the garlic whole kids Nino
don't like garlic all these this is
flavored it yeah so it's not easy to
take the garlic now al bouri a rice that
Basie there
as that comes up to the boil you just
take it off and it's it's that it's
after four minutes spread the rice on a
tray to cool down that's really good now
the kids saw that they wouldn't yes but
the fact that we flavored the rice he's
got his Nike yes that's exactly what
they'll say I don't want twigs amato I'm
gonna come with you
and pick up the kids just to show you
how easy this is
[Music]
Oh Thank You Rosie that's nice they're
ticklish next stop picking up George and
Harry and a chance to meet some of the
other mums at the school gates something
I don't get the chance to do every day
so hectic as well in terms of trying to
find time to cook in amongst the
remaining schedule I've got three
children yeah and I have to feed them
and then my husband works really late
hours so then I have to you just find it
and you're difficult to cook in amongst
of everything else you got to do Iowa
store has dropped them off Pilar tazed
back glass of wine we've all got nannies
somewhere
so with the kids picked up it's back to
the house what about homework ticket and
there's only 30 minutes before sally has
to take George to football practice of
time to get cooking right stage to the
right is part boiled and the Hatters
cooked so this stage is about bringing
the ingredients together quickly
[Music]
[Music]
something they're not used to eating
leeks so I'm gonna cut them up really
small yeah so they don't get to see them
where the Vice goes in now we're using
the milk that we poached the haddock in
earlier for a really flavorful stock so
what happens after dinner swimming
trying to get reading or homework done
so stuff alot in there it's still full
on probably it about it'll be gone eight
o'clock a spoonful of mascarpone cheese
will give a lovely creamy taste but the
kids will love think the kids will thing
[Music]
now it's gonna need about another three
or four minutes
oh it's tailor-made for your busy day
yeah definitely no this is perfect
dad's on his way home to look after the
kids before Sonny takes Georgia football
time to dish up oh that's me I'm very
well let's be a moment thank you very
much season are you ready for some
risotto check this out
this brilliant might what do you think
one darling mmm
I hope you got to keep it up yes promise
yes I would seriously stay behind and
help you but to be honest I think going
back to my own wish tonight will be a
lot easier yeah someone ladies please
Gordon yes yeah yeah there's a 100k it
is from civet 11 the huh cook they've
eaten half of it it's not raw sorry come
on
that's perfect
you weren't very happy I've got me on
Thrones to rule so 30 years ago you know
I think you got a valid point because
everyone thinks ports that'll be cooked
to hell out of to become tasty that I'm
really sorry it's cooked perfectly
what'd you do for them interesting I
know more than anyone in Britain today
that [ __ ] estate agents cannot cook so
I wouldn't expect you to understand how
that's cooked perfectly
thank you holy mackerel [ __ ] me I'm
gonna stay agent poor bastard and good
to see you buddy any well very well yeah
thanks for coming down you know food
mm-hmm he left wine I love wine I enjoy
it and I like tasting wine small round
yellow and was it true that you actually
named your dogs after wine yeah we've
got Pinot Pinot that Russell we've got
two Merlot who's a bulldog
you must sound like some strange look
because your own label now
oh there's Meryl Willis and the vineyard
comes from purchase in McLaren Vale and
Cunha Warren so isolated okay original
French great these grapes go back behind
to go back a long way yeah I want to
test the pallets the ripe again now want
to see what you are capable of
so this is the tip rigid wine challenge
okay you're gonna work - yes there's not
[ __ ] - come on they're forwarding you
did pretty appalling in his channel you
know put out the tongues for you now is
to do better than he did yes we're gonna
present two wines which is a good one
and which is the celebrity plonk
[Music]
my palate Oh check that huh
number one is Barry Manilow Chardonnay
the second one yeah my favorite batter
Maya Shay gone crew 1996 160 pound a
bottle my favorite and would you believe
clip fridges favorite as well we don't
like that Matt will be viewed barry
manilow show the same knows the fine
wine get next please take your time I
think good take this very soon
yeah congratulations there is a very
expensive shuttle montage yeah hello 7l
70 pounds 1996 the first one was it blog
um Madonna there yeah yeah 20 pounds of
bottle yet well done you equal to settle
it okay GB next wine please
one of my favorites now okay yes
wonderful okay
love it
which is the wine and which is the plum
wine number two I like that it's gotta
be worth its well mate would you pay for
that I wouldn't I wouldn't like that
style wine neither
I've got a bunch of interns around for
dinner would you said that to them put
them in the garden I'll keep that one
for myself that one okay good right and
then congratulations well done it's
yours the one you like
well done you be back this one here [ __ ]
you no babies for cliff nobody beat him
but you don't like he's white either
you know why shocking it [ __ ] is that I
wouldn't even put in my [ __ ]
polonaise right it's official cliff
Richards wine is shocking yes see-
excellent
Paul was lovely base Mikey flavorless
that was also very nice and also the
courgette was very well done it was
extremely good the pork was it was
really moist a little dry like it
sometimes is okay ladies results the
main court please quickly come over so
for checking companies you think I have
to pay for the main course what's a bad
chef 45 Geoffrey Tara I like that level
of confidence okay the number of people
they're willing to pay for the main
course is
33 out of 50 so what another plate not
but what do they say too slow - so and -
pinky - pinky yeah the word three tables
that came back and they were pink yes
damn now do yourself a favor go out on a
high
yes yes next on the menu I get behind
buffalo in search of the perfect
mozzarella mount guarded well it's time
for dessert a mouth-watering cherry
samosa
and Dom Joly is up to his old tricks in
the recipe challenge oh please
welcome back the earthwork now time to
be Dom Joly in the recipe challenge and
no he's not on the phone he's in my
kitchen yeah what you're sweating
already my man yeah the rules are simple
you choose your favorite dish okay I
have to try and match that and of course
obviously betta conditions from where
well it's a kind of slight hybrid but
it's basically a Lebanese dish that my
mum used to make what's it called well I
made it up it's cool it's called chicken
khafre's that's the village I grew up in
Lebanon but it's a kind of lemon garlic
chicken thing in the oven right with a
Lebanese green bean salad good luck
thank you yes
so don't do the Lebanese styled chicken
dish and I'm doing something sort of
slightly Moroccan it's most amazing
breasts of chicken sauteed well they're
really nice crisscross but finished with
the ratatouille and apple and then sauce
with a really nice lemon olive oil don't
be okay yeah I'm doing my Keith Floyd up
to me okay first we're going to steam
the couscous salt pepper a little bit of
vegetable stock and then some olive oil
and then just gently over BAM ray just
steam the couscous so were you in there
garlic yeah so crush garlic I'm just
gonna fry up some onions and garlic with
a bit of sumac in olive oil then brown
the chicken and then put it all in the
oven for about 40 minutes and you get
like a really lemony garlicky chicken if
it works if it doesn't taste horrible
now your natural with food well I grew
up in Lebanon so we had lots of Lebanese
food which is I like Lebanese just lots
of different little dishes yeah and it's
kind of influenced from everywhere what
was it like growing up Barry it was cool
till I was about six and then the Civil
War started yeah and then it was things
like going to school here in England
uh-huh and bringing out my shrapnel
collection and realizing that I was the
only one with one you know it's that
kind of thing yes so were you in there
garlic yeah sort of crush garlic I'm a
thing and this is soo much I really like
Oh lovely which is a kind of Lebanese
I'm not quite sure if you can tell me
but it's very lemony this is going to
drive Barry you know like this driver is
a driver absolutely let's use a lot sort
of instead of lemons but I'm putting it
in with some lemon to make it uber
lemony so people don't like lemon or a
bit buggered on this one
rumor has it used to be a vegetarian yes
here do not regret all those wasted
years totally do y'all feel guilty you
don't look like a vegetarian or no or a
man that has been a vegetarian but I did
when I was younger was a very thin god I
wasn't I was worse Dom stop
I was it God vegetarian I was now all I
do is just color the chicken breast I
love that glass of wine you know they
haven't put that down since you've been
here I've never bottled straight
hilarious and what you do with the beans
I basically just fry them up with garlic
and onion LOX just salt and then put in
count a really thick tomato go inside my
pan here got my red onion aubergine and
courgette quickly started off with a
little bit of cumin and the cumin flavor
it's got a really sort of enhance the
vegetables and then we're gonna mix that
through the couscous Kumar to sweeten it
up a bit of coriander
you ready to [ __ ] on the oven yeah
yeah right I'm ready it's right that's
done my chicken go in the oven now then
it comes out quite simple Dom loses now
it's time for dessert cherry samosas
[Music]
English cherries absolutely phenomenal
they're only here to the end of orders
to take full advantage of them really
shortly expensive worth every penny
we're going to make the most amazing
fresh cherry samosa caster sugar
[Music]
as the sugar starts to turn into caramel
add the cherries
roll around
lemons
Josh
they're brilliantly well with the
cherries in the camera [ __ ] hell
flambe and then just add a couple
tablespoons of water the lemon
meds
[Applause]
leaving the cooldown for five minutes
and then we'll wrap them in phyllo
pastry the most important thing about
feeler paste
never ever make it always buy it it's
very thin stretch pastry and perfect for
samosa will cut the feel up in half
a nice long rectangle shape clarified
butter
four or five cherries in the corner Tata
cream and sit it on top old
[Applause]
I just fold over and stick it down
[Music]
clarified butter in she goes 3540
seconds each side now on to the player
sugar roll
little touch of cherry compote from the
plate
cherry samosas with clotted cream done
let's go footballs away let's go why are
you putting through innocent eyes before
yes Brutus Muslim I'm sure yes chef try
this at home yes your money Pratt would
love it good let's go I'll boost the
plates you cook the samosas let's go
please [ __ ] you know what we're doing
shallow frying them come on okay I
thought we could cook samosas if there's
one person here can get this right it
should be you know let's go ladies
please this would be nice to end on a
high come on okay let's go
several nine
[Music]
time for a new Scottish delicacy buffalo
mozzarella I'm all the way to a buffalo
farm in Fife hoping that we can make
Scotland's first-ever batch of fresh
buffalo mozzarella cheese
as a nation we now produce more
mozzarella than Italy sadly it's protest
mozzarella all from cow's milk and
nothing to do with Buffalo's milk so
this from a chef's point of view it's a
very exciting journey
[Music]
I'm going to mean Buffalo farmer Steven
Mitchell in five who's got me at my
sports car and into something more
suited for herding beasts that weigh a
ton
Stevens been farming buffalo for meat
for three years but he's never made
cheese until today
[Applause]
we need to round them up to milk them
but they don't all move without a fight
[Music]
let's go now we rounded them up
we've got pick out the females were the
biggest others to milk but I'm a bit
distracted by the size of Stephens bull
he's monstrous what's his name
he's called Marquis come on I'm dying to
jump on him I know kicking me off he
swept me off before how do I stop him
cross the break Malky oh [ __ ] you better
hope it doesn't try to jump back over
Gandhi are you talking about round
Malcolm so I think that was in season oh
[ __ ] okay that's creepy
oh that one 660 this one's our training
for the marathon huh [ __ ] comes go go
go shut the gates out the gate one two
three babe
[Music]
good I'm knackered already and we still
got to milk the thing and make the
cheese I'm gonna let you have a shot yes
you can get some of that milk out when
you're bent down there look you may be
more worried about the the kicking ID
watching it for the [ __ ] ready well
you're right below a bum it's out of
something again further back okay she's
not gonna come back again come back okay
monkey
now she's pissing oh you know your
combination [ __ ] and piss you stimulate
their organs you're just using one
finger what's good you know so you just
squeeze bringing it there but not
pulling they all Hey well guarded milk
okay find me just when I thought I got
the hang of it the milk came out in
pints all over me where's the twice a
day crazy [ __ ] letter get out there
tell me once we've extracted the first
bit of milk by hand the machine does the
rest which keeps the milk squeaky-clean
for the cheese
that's amazing that you know well they
say the fresher the better for their old
BOTS our army as this is gonna be
Scotland's first ever mozzarella Stephen
has called in experts Horace and his son
Mike to give us a hand
how are we well this is the first for me
I've never made a mozzarella ever before
so I'm gonna eat the milk up to heat up
to 42 degrees yeah okay and then we're
gonna add the cultures straight to the
vent the heat up the milk and add the
cultures this starts the cheese-making
process yeah so we take it off the heat
leave that to cool down now ours are now
the water in the milk called the way
separates and it's thrown away the curd
is left and is melted with boiling water
to make mozzarella process okay good
we're now turning it from curd into
mozzarella yeah okay so we just mix it
together melting it together together so
I'm kneading it together
that's it love look at that stretch out
okay they forward together well is like
a giant piece of Shimei 1h need they all
need the corners into the other side
linen for your fingers sugar your
fingers now that's the way you've got it
Steve you got it that's it
there we go that's the first course once
at elbow this perfectly shiny yeah he's
got bigger balls I'm a big was a more
perfectly round
maturity my man maturity sit Stevens are
some friends and family over and I'm
doing a barbecue to celebrate burgers
with buffalo meat and Scotland's
first-ever buffalo mozzarella
I can't wait be perfect burger again
this time we lose Buffalo mania
definitely yeah so far we mix the
buffalo mince with red onion mustard
garlic and a good splash of Worcester
sauce and Tabasco
a small affair with your mates they'll
get it Oh get upset yeah yeah again
yours is bigger than mine when the
burgers are nearly done I'm going to top
them off with mozzarella yeah but first
I will use it to make a delicious salad
okay here we go
that's beautiful yeah where is their
love milk so Susan any of it dad is so
creamy
that's a beautiful light I've got a
really nice treat me about this I think
this is gonna take off you know just put
it on there like that nice and then with
a big tomato
just get it sliced season with salt and
pepper
it's all new rule extra-virgin olive oil
yeah color the olive oil now when it
hits somewhat Sorella it's extraordinary
and I'm just gonna chop the basil and
then just sprinkle it over there and
then finally a lemon juice just brings
it together this is the bit I've been
waiting for I swear to God I have a
little taste
oh my god oh that's what do tasty
it's good well done well done and clever
percentages please that is delicious
it's this fantastic absolutely I'm
speechless the other side Corrections on
the pressures on the trimmers and Watts
turn on top as well
Beauty melted Scottish buffalo
mozzarella done buddy yes unfortunately
my hands still smell of [ __ ] now time to
find out the results of the recipe
challenge oh please Ramsay I'm just
about a threat Jimmy's that's my phone
right yes oh yes you ready right
are you excited terrified are you
nervous I'm not nervous but I'm
competitive so I want to [ __ ] win
yeah but you got a bit of an advantage
in that you're a Top Chef and I'm a
squirrel
so did Yoshi taste yours yes I did did
you it was delicious it always like to
seem together like that look I think
that I'm look you know I go for that you
see that's to punster yeah no it's just
decent peasant food yeah it looks like a
[ __ ] camel's who fried John Baptist
off you go Matt yep yes just let me know
yeah lemon chicken Khafre with a super
saucy troll yes super song le couteau
yeah
hi how are you okay so those dish in the
second one whatever
[Applause]
couscous was good but the chickens
cooked well not dry
I like that it's very succulent it's
very well cooked that's really nice
the chicken is the Gentile apple fingers
done really well it's nice that yes
yeah I prefer the flavors in the green
bean chicken I think that the chicken
was a lot more succulent give me the
good news
obviously hankfurter turn-screw all over
the wire well yeah goes to school
three - two three - yeah so quite close
in three two - he's French oh well he's
got okay come on say we know what
putting a bit more work be fine I'm
really quite chuffed about that we did
before
[ __ ] off [ __ ] about my kid sorry I
supposed to be the pleasure yeah I wish
I could say the same
next on the menu is it just desserts for
the Desperate Housewives a amount of
customers they're having to pay five
pound is
and there's tragic news from the beckons
estate Leslie I'm absolutely [ __ ]
gobsmacked and it was definitely
Charlotte
walking back the f-word now some
shocking news about my lambs and trust
me it's not for the faint-hearted my
sheep have been on the Beckham's for
just two weeks when their estate workers
made a terrible discovery
[Music]
I'm absolutely [ __ ] gobsmacked and it
was definitely Charlotte asked the vet
to come down and just yeah at least like
that we'll find out exactly how she was
killed or eaten we'll do I'll get back
to you about it to him ah [ __ ] hell
bad news ah later that day the boys
called in bet he'll only and she rushed
to the scene we have to find out what
killed it
we can try I think we'll have to take
the carcass away to do a post-mortem
plan to put the rest of my flock in a
safe place they put them in the victims
stable block where they could be locked
up at night Charlotte was born at made
sheep farm in Wales so I called him to
break the news and asked if he'd ever
experienced anything like this before
I measured Etana I mean started thinking
how I'm gonna break that one to the kids
does that happen up there right yeah
absolutely when you've got a flock of
three four hundred sheep fine but when
you've got four yeah just when I thought
I'd had enough surprises Victoria's
father sent me a newspaper which
deepened the mystery this is recent this
is a piece in the local newspaper of a
possible wild cat on the loose I heard
back from the vet worryingly her autopsy
couldn't rule out a big cat attack so
she sent the results to a specialist
forensic scientist for a second opinion
with so many questions I have to find
out what happened to Charlotte so I'll
return to the beckham's field yeah and
that's where you found her place was
here and felt it was going around there
and then the actual rest of the body was
pulled over to help start that longer
grass there I invited calling out come a
big cat keeper the local wildlife park
to join us to see if he could lend some
insight the only way we could find out
what a killed shot was to view some
footage in detail
nothing could have prepared me for this
meat to be stripped off absolutely
savaged what a dog do that it's very
extreme vet had only had received a
second post-mortem report that morning
I've got a report from the pathologist
at the veterinary laboratories agency
she actually sought advice from a
full-time forensic bettery pathologist
at the University so it's going right to
the top try got the answers for you he
confirmed that predation by a large cat
cannot be excluded in this case given
the method of killing by dislocation of
the neck and then remove
oceans of the body yeah I mean that's a
very intense report but it is yeah
they're not ruling out a possible cat
lots of speculation about so-called big
cats being around in Britain Pumas links
there to possible cats that yet people
claim to see a lot of oh he's such a
savage exactly
stripped of the carcass hardly any flesh
left you're saying it's been strangled
fight round the neck which is classic
for a cat kill Mitch was actually eaten
off very very neatly that's what the
phone's just come in sandwich which
nickeled on her mind cuz the dog
wouldn't all resource average at it and
break bones and you know tear at the
flesh yes it's certainly unusual small
possibility of one of these I find this
whole big cat story absolutely
incredible so and what I talk to the
locals to see if they're spotted one big
enough to kill Charlotte there is a cat
on the loose yet definitely I was a
couple of miles away on an early morning
run I just saw this kind of black
creature cat thing and it didn't trot it
kind of glided really across the road I
was going home from work late quite dark
really great big muscular black thing
front of my car frightened me to death
and it was the start of adult but it
looked like a cat it was your saw went
about four years ago when it been in the
bank it was big enough to sort of eat a
lamb yeah no doubt in my mind it could
do something like that an animal of that
size that was probably about three or
four weeks ago I'm convinced they're out
there and certainly there's one around
the half at your area I contacted the
police but they said there's not enough
evidence so therefore they're not to be
launching a full investigation but
personally I'm so desperate to find out
what really happened to Charlotte
it was actually a little bit too sweet
the cherries and the mascarpone could be
a little bit more evenly distributed
inside sometimes the ends are a little
bit dry but on the whole it's very very
nice very tasty results for dessert yes
Jackie how do you think it is 50/50
that's confident you know okay MRSA
Queen the Indian way that's 50 heather
5848 the amount of customers they're
happy to pay five pound this most is
46 out of that means a grand total of a
hundred and nine out of a hundred and
fifty and unfortunately not be coming
back to clarity's the experience is
fantastic well done